cheetahs can reach up to 70 miles an
hour in just three seconds
if you were to look at the actual speed
that a human being could run
you're probably looking at 30 kilometers
an hour but only for a very short period
of time
what's the difference
cheater
the cheetah is able to run up to 70
miles an hour
and everything about their physiology
and their body
is designed for them to reach very quick
speeds in a very short period of time
i think one of the most unique aspects
of the cheetah
is the fact that about 50 percent of
their entire body mass
is made of muscle the type of fibers
that
a cheetah has compared to the type of
muscle fibers that we have
are much more heavily weighted towards
fast twitch fibers
and they are better able to contract
at a much more quick pace over 80
percent of the musculature
in the thigh or the top of the back leg
in the cheetah
is made up of these fast twitch muscle
fibers that's an
enormously large proportion of that
muscle type which
is what enables them to reach amazingly
fast speeds
cheetahs have a very large psoas muscle
which is
what helps extend out the hip
and then pull it back into the body very
quickly and powerfully and that
extension
and inflection is what enables them to
push off very strongly with their back
legs
and generate that power take a look at
this video of this cheetah running at
high speed
watch as the cheetah is sprinting those
hind legs
extend out and are pulled back very
quickly and
very powerfully and you can see that
spine flex
when the cheetah is in full stride you
can see that everything about it is
built for being aerodynamic even the
ears are pulled back against the head
cutting down on any wind friction
another thing to note they actually have
a four beaded gate
very similar to a horse when it is
galloping but
unlike other species the cheetah has two
moments
in its stride when all four feet are off
the ground at the same time
[Music]
if you think about the difference
between a flat-footed wok and almost a
tip-toe walk
the cheetah has some unique musculature
whereby
it can be ready for action ready to
start that sprint
almost on a on the spur of the moment
when you're trying to run
at speed we are really only
hitting or striking the ground with the
ball of the foot
and the toes the reason why we are doing
this is because we are trying to employ
the
foot as an additional lever with which
to propel ourselves forward
take a look at this we have a lever from
the hip
to the knee we have another lever from
the knee to the ankle
we have a third lever from the ankle to
the ball of the foot and the last lever
is from the ball of the foot to the toes
this allows us to use the muscles of the
foot
and of the lower leg from the calf
downwards
to generate power when the foot is
contacting the ground
so let's take a look at a cheetah foot
so not much of the bottom of the the
cheetah foot the actual bones of the
cheetah foot are in touch
with the ground the nails are always
extended acting like those track cleats
when the animal sprints
you can see there's only four toes here
the middle two toes
are the most weight bearing so they take
the brunt of all of the cheetah's weight
you may wonder what happened to the
fifth toe that is actually what we know
as the dewclaw
that is what they use to trip up their
prey
when they're chasing after it as they
reach the back legs of their prey
they hook those back legs with that
dewclaw
causing the animal to trip and stumble
and then they can
jump in and finish the kill so you'll
notice when the cheetah is sprinting
after its prey
it doesn't go in a straight line the
prey is trying to get away from the cat
and so it makes a zigzag motion when
it's running
it gets very close to the ground almost
touching its side to the ground and it's
able to do that because
those nails those claws on its feet are
helping to give it
a lot of traction and stability
the cheetah's breast bone isn't well
attached to the rest of their
musculature they call it a free-floating
breastbone they have
a chest cavity which allows a much
larger expansion of space that's
available to expand the lungs
and that actually enables them to have a
lot of flexibility in the front
and to really stretch out that stride
when they're sprinting
humans don't do that because we are
tuned to be
generalists and do lots of things human
respiration
when you're exercising can go anywhere
from 20 to 24 are probably even higher
at maximal capacity
when a cheetah sprints they have a
respiration rate of around 150 breaths
per minute
[Music]
cheetahs disperse heat in several
different ways their body temperature
goes up
so much when they're doing those very
quick fast sprints
for human beings we're fortunate to have
a number of ways in which we can
dissipate heat the easiest to think
about is through perspiration
when we are generating heat we can start
to sweat
and the movement of air across the water
that's on the surface of the skin
will allow us to cool ourselves down
cheetahs
can release heat through their mouth and
even through their
feet another mechanism that we have for
dissipating heat
is through the hairs on the surface of
our skin when we're trying to retain
heat the hairs on our arms will stand up
in order to slow the movement of air
across the surface of the skin
when we are trying to dissipate heat we
will make sure that those
hairs all lay flat so that we can lose
as much heat to the moving air as
possible
the black spots on the cheetah are
thought to also help disperse heat
the hairs of the black spots are
actually longer
than the hairs that are the yellowish to
orange color
so those longer hairs are thought to
help disperse and release the heat
the last mechanism that we can use to
dissipate heat
is through our respiration itself when
our core temperature
increases the air on the inside of us
will also be
increased in temperature and as we
expire
that warm air we will inspire cool air
coming in
which allows us to disperse heat through
that mechanism
and then cheetahs are of course able to
pant like you see
dogs and cats do sometimes they have to
decrease their body temperature before
they can consume their kill
the cheetah has a very flexible spine
which enables it to move quickly
especially to zigzag when it's chasing
prey
when it comes to sprinting flexibility
is something that's quite important
take a look at this video of a human
sprinting this is your stride length and
our goal
is to maximize that stride length when
we are moving through space
the way that we do this is by increasing
the flexibility
of the hip knee and the ankle
joint in order to cover ground as
quickly as possible
the cheetah also has a very heavily
muscled back which
helps that spine extend and flex so that
they can
stretch out when they're sprinting and
really gain those
long strides
[Music]
the cheetah tail is about 50 percent of
the length
of the entire rest of the structure so
it's very long
in proportion to the entire animal and
that tail
acts as a rudder so it helps it steer
around sharp corners when they're
zigzagging and chasing after their prey
it's also a very muscular tail and so
that helps as a counter balance or a
counterweight
so that they don't lose their balance as
they're
sprinting and turning quickly
so let's take a look at a cheetah skull
so the cheetah skull is very rounded and
concave across the top
and that helps it be very aerodynamic
just like the rest of its body
the human skull on the other hand is not
designed for a specific purpose
but it is designed to allow us to be
good at a number of different things
there's a couple of things that are
unique about the
human skull one of the most obvious
things is the size of the cranial vault
which
holds your brain and relative to other
animals you'll find that the cranial
vault for humans is quite large and this
is because our brains are quite large
cheetahs have really large eye sockets
and they're true predators those eyes
are faced
forward scanning all the time for
potential prey
because we are bipedal animals we are
able to see a much further distance
because of our point of perspective
cheetahs also have
teeth designed for tearing muscle meat
very quickly and ingesting as much as
possible in a very short period of time
they're called bolters they actually
bolt their meat they can eat up to 10 to
15 pounds of food at a time
and to be able to consume up to 15
percent of their
body mass and food is an amazing amount
of food that they can eat all at one
time
in order for humans to run as fast as a
cheetah this is how they would have to
change
i would want to make sure that the
muscles on both the front and the back
of the thigh
were as large as possible i would want
to
shorten the length from the hip to the
knee
but i would probably lengthen the lever
from the knee down
i would make the foot so that the heel
of the foot was suspended in the air
we could end up having claws to propel
ourselves
much more efficiently every time that we
contact the ground
i would also want to make sure that the
muscles of the
shoulders and upper chest were quite
large with the floating breastbone in
the front
in order to increase the turnover those
are some of the things that i would do
to
create the ideal sprinting human
i understand
is
you